[Music]
when i was a freshman in college at
vassar shout out i needed an off-campus
job and so i got one just off campus it
was the street next door it was a deli
they had pizza there and so i started
delivering pizzas and working the
register and the guy who owned it was a
man named i'm going to give a fake name
because frankly i'm a little scared of
him i will call him bill
bill owned the place with another man
named let's call him steve you're so
clever with these names no well their
real names were also very basic okay
very run-of-the-mill so i wanted to give
them equally run-of-the-mill pseudonyms
that's funny so bill who owned the place
had a huge head and he claimed to have
been in a crime family one day his
partner steve did not show up and i said
where is steve um and he said hey uh i
caught him skimming and i said so where
is he he said well i i gave him an offer
i said uh
you can kee you can keep the money and
lose your legs or uh
you can give the money back and i never
see you again and keep your legs
and there's a long pause and he said he
decided to keep his legs
who knows what really happened but
that's the story he said and steve never
came back bill would sell alcohol to
kids who were clearly kids like 10 11
years old and the cops would drive by
and he would wave at him hi officer
and the cops would wave back you know he
was clearly paying everything and you
were deep in you were like donny brasco
i was yeah i know like a less cool not
like a rat not like donald
yes now i'm like um who was the guy in
goodfellas that goodfellas was about oh
uh uh ray liotta yes yes was um oh my
god is this killing me well let's think
about it okay after this song all right
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i mean
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my uh
don't rope me into your crime family
christian um it was it sounds like
charlie day
yeah yeah a little bit it was a little
bit like this and he would laugh like
this
um i want to say harold hill hill harold
hill
henry hill oh yeah henry hill
as you're looking it up i beat i know i
just want to confirm google henry hill
yeah he was um
a little bit like henry hill ended up
being a big he's known for being a
snitch a rat uh which is not necessarily
a bad thing
depending on who you're writing on it
you don't want to offend any rats out
there no no
it's okay if you're going to be in the
witness protection program i wonder if
anyone's listening in the witness
protection program i wonder if anyone
was listening in the mafia
yes you know why i'm glad i used those
fake names i think the mafia is still
okay to
make light of not make light of but to
uh like make fun of
you to like give [ __ ] you know uh you
think i think it's a group that you're
allowed to tease
i mean at your own risk right obviously
like you don't want to observe people
well i know but i'm saying in terms of
like the political correctness of it oh
politically yeah political promise was i
i still but even saying like italian i
don't want to be offensive to italian
america but you are an italian american
yes so i think because of that you're
maybe allowed to uh
poke fun at them maybe um you're not
that italian american no not to the
point where i i don't think i'd ever be
a maid man i think you have to be 100
i for a few reasons you might not be a
maid man that's right i was just
considering the ethnic one that i think
you have to be wasn't that the thing
good fellas like de niro's character was
irish so he couldn't be made
but uh i continued to work there and
he opened up a video store under
in the basement it didn't bother you
that they were
um involved in organized crime i really
needed money i thought he was that
shouldn't be number one number one was i
i kind of thought at the time it it it
happened so gradually that he revealed
that this is what he was a part of um
and at first i truly truly thought he
was full of [ __ ] i thought he was making
it up and
he still may have been i mean
the person may have just left the person
uh steve may have just left of his own
volition yeah out of curiosity why um
why are you talking about this story
well i'm talking about it because it was
the first time i witnessed such an
extreme
version of you know severance package um
okay so so
steve had been fired by bill basically
fired and he was given an offer
um a severance package of just keeping
his limbs intact i guess that counts as
a severance package it's better
because speaking of seth
speaking of severance
our guest today is the star of the apple
tv show the incredible apple tv show
severance
how about that okay are these
okay are these getting um
more roundabouts
i think there's something fun and
delightful about their roundabout yeah
so okay i hope i hope people agree with
that um but yeah adam scott is our guest
today star of not just severance another
one of our favorite step brothers
uh parks and rec is a beloved beloved
beloved he's not the star of beloved
no that was remember that one yeah tony
morrison yes sure now pro winfrey
probably alfred o'brien free hopefully a
future friend of the show oh hopefully
hopefully future guests
and he was in
um he's in everything he's he's great in
everything um i've always liked adam i
remember meeting him and you know we'd
meet at like in waiting rooms of
auditions i remember one specifically
when we spent like significant time
together was when we were both
auditioning for
uh zethora the movie the zethora that
john favreau movie and it came down to
um the two of us and dax shepard and so
so it was the three of us kind of like
we'd go in and out of this room they
call it mix and match um so you you wait
in the waiting room you go in and they
just keep they keep sending people home
and whittling down the number and i was
there with adam for a while and i liked
him so much even in that like
high-stakes situation um and whenever i
would hear about him getting a job i
always thought oh good you know it makes
sense that you'd be competing for the
same role you're you're not that
different uh typewise yeah i guess so
you know yes yeah and so you would think
i'd be kind of competitive maybe with
somebody like that but i i never will
not if you're not a competitive person
yeah i guess so but i would get
competitive with other people i would
feel a sense of competition especially
in my 20s you know but now that you're
in your 40s i don't care about anything
yeah except gardening you've given up
yeah i just wanna i care about what my
vegetables look like and um that's not a
euphemism no no i no longer care about
that either that you've missed them i um
but adam was somebody i always liked and
and i was so glad to get the time to sit
down and talk with him and uh let's get
into uh my ketchup with my old waiting
room pal
the star of severance and so many other
great things the very funny adam scott
life could be a dream
[Music]
well
i finally got it oh no are you uh
feeling like [ __ ] right now it's so
funny adam i was like don't talk about
coping don't talk about your code but
it's like yeah
it's hard to avoid because i probably
sound a little
sick it's some it's
i i i just had that arrogance of like
one boosted and yeah what's gonna happen
but but despite that i had been like
really careful i was like
mask everywhere i was the one guy i'm
trying to retrace where i may have
gotten from and i got my first like
non-job haircut you know when you have
to like finally spring for a haircut i
was like didn't work
and the guy was
everybody was massless and they i was in
connecticut they just lifted
the mandate and um
uh so i kept it on but you know and i i
just called him and he's he doesn't have
it i ran into a
in this another hairdresser on the plane
who i think may have been the culprit he
was he's a real close talker
and and he we were masked but like he
was like hey how are you you know
right up in my own sounds like maybe you
needed to stay away from hairdressers
that's
the lesson
for everyone yeah just get the [ __ ] away
from them yeah buy a flowbee
man that sucks
i'm fine if you want to wait till you're
no no better no i this is i'm sorry to
bring it down no i i did have it i had
it though i had covered classic i had it
oh you're the original or before the
vaccine oh oh
oh gee
like oh gee covey um
was it was it um
so you quarantined for because you have
kids you must have had to quarantine
from that i was i was in new york
shooting the show so i was by myself
anyway so it was i just sort of holed up
and
waited it out but you know it's it's no
fun the another you know byproduct of
this is just like i get to sit around
and watch
watch tv and like catch up and on things
and um
so i started watching severance and it's
so good i feel like you would be able to
come up with a good name for this it's
you know at the end of an episode these
like streaming things now where
there's a feeling of almost like
frustration it's like adjacent to like
anger where something is so good that
you're like oh [ __ ] this means i have to
watch the whole thing yeah like i now
have to commit
hours no i don't know where there's nine
years it's a lot of time
it is and it's you have to i've had that
a few times with shows it's not often
but like i really think there should be
a word for like the japanese probably
have a word for it they do i i looked it
up yeah okay you don't want to share it
the streaming frustration um
no it is like it's just roku and in just
conversation with people now it's like
oh have you seen the dropout or pam and
tommy or whatever it's like oh no i
haven't i i need to get started on that
and it's like we all have these
lingering
10-hour commitments just that we have to
get to i know i know back in the day it
was like you see seinfeld like yeah you
missed it someone would say or like
you'll see it next week maybe i'll see
it in two years in syndication that was
about it
it's really uh
labor-intensive but the binge-ability of
severance is that it did did you feel
that reading was it like that was it
like a page
wait what the [ __ ] yeah how much of that
isn't stiller how much that is direction
it's a a lot of it is still or a lot of
it is dan erickson who
created it and and wrote it and there
were also a room of of terrific writers
as well and dan was um was over it's all
his world and his idea and everything um
yeah it's it's a combination of those
two things and reading them it was
always and
shooting it it was always like
well
if
this works and
if people are
with us
this is going to be a great last scene
of the episode or whatever well because
it is i've noticed i noticed this too
that it there's something and i don't
want to
sell it in the wrong way or i don't want
to turn people off it i guess but it is
very
it's not slow it's patient it's like
unusually patient the way these these
like sterile um
tracking shots and and steadicam stuff
down those hall it's like it's beautiful
it's like this dystopian it
beautifully done thing but it's um
especially when you compare it to like
shows now especially comedies now where
it's like
so quick and everything's so frenetic um
that must have been
in that way it feels bold like a new
thing so it's yeah it should feels
different than
than other stuff uh
right now and and that's part of the
reason i was terrified when i bet you
know it was coming out because it's a
big swing and yes um
and uh you never know i mean i i
liked it and
then like we all felt good about what we
did but you know but you must have had
that feeling yeah exactly you know you
don't know how something's i was in
walter mitty with that then directed and
i loved that and it got
torn apart uh no you know such a
surprise i i remember hearing about that
for a long time and i know that was
stillers like he that was like his
passion project for so long and he's one
of my favorite directors and i just
assume oh man he's i've heard you talk
about cable guy a lot
because i listen to this show i know oh
adam thanks oh man i shouldn't have
stepped on that thank you that's nice
but you you you uh yeah you love uh
cable guys
and all that stuff and and yeah i i i'm
just you know one of the things that's
so nice is that people are with this and
and dan amara and now
looking back
recognizing hit ben's filmmaking for
what it is which is incredible
did people like stiller start calling
after was it step brothers that changed
things drastically
or was it prior to that was i guess it
was like a two three year period it
feels like where it was step brothers
party
definitely are the things that
catapulted me
into the stratosphere
[Music]
well boy this world has done that for
many
actors were you ever on boy
yeah
i think it was just before my time i
would have loved to have
um
what would you like to thank you
you you know the boy meets world team
it must have been a relief just to have
an acting job at that point just to like
give it a yeah i remember i was
doing that and then murder one at the
same time do you remember that
yes
yeah he was like artely savalas he was
artelli savalas and i think he was
married to kim cattrall uh oh this was
1995 when i was going back and forth
between the
recurring parts on these two shows and
thought i was
real hot [ __ ] i bet
i bet two roles at the same time were
you is it how long had you wanted to do
that i mean were you um
as a kid yeah you strike me as um
somebody who was
had maybe a different path to it
you seem a lot less performative yeah i
just got interested in it because of
raiders of the lost ark like because i
was like in the second grade when that
came out so simon pegg a couple we said
this similarly really specifically that
might yeah yeah i mean that movie was
yeah oh yeah everything it's still i
mean i still watch it a couple times a
year it's
i see i hadn't seen it in a while and i
thought i should revisit those this
couple years ago and god does that hold
up it's better it like has gotten better
it's like aged like a fine one and you
know i kind of
i know i'm in the minority but i think
temple of doom is my favorite
it's the darkest it's [ __ ] it's it's
grim but it's um why did that get
because it got worse reviews it was like
didn't do as well yeah i think
the depiction of
uh kate capshaw's character
maybe hasn't aged the best oh yes wait
yeah like dams on distress yeah the idea
of this they should cancel over whoever
did that that she cancelled her wishes
you cancel everybody
spielberg yeah yeah yeah um
they should cancel whoever played you
know what let's cancel each other while
we're at it
uh
well you go first it's like a murder
suicide that's fine that's why yeah
but if you cancel me i can't cancel i
cancel you and then i just cancel myself
and then
turn off the computers
um
and that's how the problem is i think
that one it was like a sequel
from the planet see it kind of defined
sequels just like more
but do people when people find out
you're the youngest of three because i'm
the middle of three
um
do do they have is there some sort of
they say oh that makes sense or
um
does it
do have you heard that before that it
that it um
that you act like a youngest yeah i'm
inherently insulted i think my wife
would be like
yeah yeah he's the youngest what if like
what but she if she were on what would
she say is like a trait of like a like a
youngest sibling trait
just
got away with a lot of i was just
telling my son who's 15
last night telling him a story about
how i used to try and get fake ids a lot
which is a great story to tell your 15
year old i don't know why i was doing
this why were you uh because he was
talking about how he was on a field trip
recently and all the
seniors at his high school on the field
trip had fake ids and went and got beers
when they were on some field trip anyway
do you immediately start doing the math
like because oh this could be a
formative talk this could be a formative
moment like i got to be really careful
do you find yourself being
self-conscious or about yes um there's
that but then there's also
you know uh
trying to find
a
because you know when you're 15
you are
and you're talking to your parents
you're always looking for the trap door
out of the room how can i get back to my
room
and talk to my friends right right
play
video games what you know how do i
minimize this experience exactly so i
was trying to keep him in the kitchen a
little longer
for me that's funny to to deliver a
message like to make a point the message
was beside the point i was just trying
to continue the facetime
not the apple facetime but actual
facetime
yeah um and the the the message you
should say like face face time now face
face time double face time yeah the the
actual message ended up coming around
but i i have to admit i didn't i was
just starting with cool story was all i
was
going for at the time okay well that's
very honest with you that wasn't i like
that that was your agenda well isn't it
it's a good lesson actually maybe if you
don't like force an agenda yeah one you
can find one you're fine if you don't
just make one up
um what what was so what was it well i
we used to go i grew up in santa cruz so
we used to drive up to berkeley when we
were in high school and get fake ids at
the place where you would go stand in
front of a
giant id and just have your face in the
mason you know
like a cut out like a cut a giant
and someone would just take a picture of
it and then give it to you
um yeah and it would just say oregon and
then you make up a name
and a birthday yeah
and it worked at one place twice and
that's it
um
is oregon o-r-o-g yeah exactly
um
so what i ended up doing was
i
went to city hall
in santa cruz
i
got my brother's birth certificate
who's five years older than me so i was
16.
he's 21. i said hi my name's david
scott i would like my birth certificate
please and they gave it to me
i then got in my 68 rambler and drove
to
the dmv
and stood in line presented my
birth certificate and
got a california id a real california id
holy [ __ ] yeah oh the whole time just
like am i going to be arrested right now
is this about to happen i'm 16. and so a
few weeks later it arrives in the mail
at my mother's house
she
opens it without thinking about who it's
addressed to and takes a look at it
and it's just like
huh
and gives it to my brother and then my
brother sits me down and he's like hey
uh can you tell me what this is
was where did he have authority over you
were you like to the point where you
were nervous around him well yeah i mean
so he was 21 22 and i was 15 16 and uh
he was yeah he he was he always looked
out for me and
you know uh was
in many ways my you know my
best most dependable friend and my big
brother he
introduced me to led zeppelin and
talking heads and rem and u2 and and
also
pulled the beer away from me if he
thought that i wasn't ready to have
four you know whatever it was okay but
but it wasn't like you can't have one it
wasn't like a narc he was no he was like
okay
yeah he was cool but also like setting
some limits um yeah
and he did not let me keep that idea i
was gonna yeah
now this would never work
well yeah i know what would they do now
i mean
kids must have a much better way also
getting
fake ids um do you think your son is in
i imagine he's very well adjusted and
you i'm sure you wouldn't tell him a
story like that if there was he was in
any danger of like
falling um straying from like a good
path yeah no he's he has a good hand on
his shoulders and and i think you know
it's also different now uh you know when
i was a teenager you know we would
you know
especially in a small town you had kind
of less
uh
uh there you were kind of a bit
you know i mean when i was
11 i would leave the house in the
morning and during the summer and not
come back till the sun was going down oh
totally down you know yes yes i remember
that yeah come back with like
dirt and like things
yes i know i know i i think that's still
adam like a there's a part of me but
occasionally when it's dusk and it's my
favorite time of day
um right is this you know especially
like that in the summer to week i grew
up in the east coast and it was a little
different in the summertime
because there was
it smelled like it smelled like like
freedom it smelled like yeah the grass
like the top of a baby said yeah
but i still there's a sense that like
oh this is a special time i've been like
doing stuff all day and like this is a
time where i know i'm supposed to wind
down but i kind of don't want to kind of
want to keep going with my friends yeah
but i'm hungry
and i need that dinner that i'm not
gonna i don't have any money so i i have
no way for curing food i have to go home
but they would
i remember my dad would get a booming
voice my my parents were both teachers
as well um they were oh cool
yeah but he would call us christian
justin
and the kids would all make fun of me
for it so i i'd try to be a little bit
closer to the time i knew he was gonna
call us so he wouldn't sure um
scream what did your parents teach
uh my dad was a uh he was he's retired
now obviously he's he was a biology
professor at the junior college in santa
cruz
uh microbiology marine biology he's kind
of uh oh cool yeah yeah really
brilliant guy uh my mom
was a special ed teacher at the
high school i actually went to
so she was like around school oh she was
around what was that yeah yeah it was
fine like she was a she was really cool
and
uh like a cool fun mom like all my
friends
since i was a little kid could curse
around her and when they were at my
house they could
yeah it was a it was like
everyone
like they would walk in and these are
like 11 year old kids and they'd walk in
and be like hey [ __ ] you anne and she'd
be like
get over here you little [ __ ] and
everyone would laugh and it was the
coolest that's that is that's
oh man 11 year old me is so jealous oh
yeah yeah yeah
my mom would occasionally let like rip
on the phone i mean she would say like
wild [ __ ] if she was like worked up or
something uh but we weren't allowed i i
think i may have said this before but i
remember adam the first time i swore i
was in third grade
and i and i um
i i've been wanting to for a while you
know
so i've been like kind of
flirting with the idea yeah
yeah which with what which one is it
going to be like yeah i have to so i
chose the like least major one i chose
the like least defensive one and um i i
went out we had this big playground um
this big field behind our school i like
made sure that i was as far away from
kids as possible and um i just said ass
i just whispered ass and i
i grew up catholic i felt guilt like
it's a big deal
oh man for days i was like
i thought i was gonna hear it's common
like the lightning bolt is coming yeah
uh trying you know and then nothing
happens the only thing person
being that heard you was like a squirrel
or a gopher out in the field yeah which
yeah a real like puritanical squirrel
that's right
[Music]
that's my
[Music]
uh know people say yeah you're a cut
above the rest that might as well be
cuts motto because they are a cut above
the rest cuts clothing has spent years
perfecting men's t-shirts taking look
good feel good to a whole new level
right out of college cuts founder and
ceo stephen barelli got a job at an
agency with a casual dress code steven
was excited he thought why i like casual
dress but in his first week he was told
his shirt was too athleisurely steven
frantically searched all over for a
presentable and stylish tea but couldn't
find any that fit the bill so he decided
to solve the problem himself designing a
premium t-shirt that could be worn
anywhere on or off the clock cuts has
tons of great colors and styles crew
necks henleys long sleeves there's
something for everyone i don't have my
cuts yet but i'm excited to try it
because i like cash i'm a casual dresser
um so i like that there might be a nicer
end of the casual spectrum for me i'm
excited refresh your wardrobe in time
for summer with cuts see for yourself
why cuts is one of the fastest growing
men's brands with over a million shirts
sold get 15 off your first order by
going to
slash
cutsclothing.com
cuts clothing dot com slash long
life is short is supported by
masterworks
two words
nft
movie friend of the show and friend of
mine kevin smith is making one
uh he's making an nft movie i'm not
exactly sure what it is but um i keep
hearing about them i know it's also
changing the art world um our sponsor
masterworks knows this better than
anyone just ask their 380 000 plus
members what they're doing is changing
the world of art it's probably why
they're already valued at a billion
dollars
their company is and they're featured in
bloomberg forbes and wall street journal
all the publications that i don't read
but probably should and if you want to
check them out you can skip their wait
list at masterworks dot art slash long
again that's masterworks dot art slash
long
[Music]
i wonder about that again like thinking
about being a dad you know i
what what would my relationship be like
with that word around my kids because
right now i [ __ ] i love
cursing
i try not to i try to reserve it
i don't want to be you know there are
those kids i remember those kids who
would like overdo it you probably
weren't one because you
then they'd be like yeah this [ __ ] i
remember uh
the guy who hosted blues clues um
when when i was first started being an
actor
he'd come to somebody i'd see him at
like you know in waiting rooms at
auditions and stuff and he i remember
once he was like
because you guys [ __ ] know where the
[ __ ] signing sheet is
you don't
we know you're not that guy you don't
have to overcome don't worry about it
i just put my [ __ ] name [ __ ]
social security
oh that's incredible just like over
indulged yeah i'm not the blues clues
guy right now i'm here
leather jacket marlboro reds like
but you can't say it i've met people
like that too i know from like um
kid uh
i don't know i feel i feel like mr
belding was a little like that or like
people that are you associate with
speaking of boy meets world with like
younger shows yeah and then you meet
them in life and you're like you're
cursing a lot
different i remember the the one time i
did the
jaylen
tonight show and he was always so
super nice and came back before and like
chatted and he came in my dressing room
and sat down
and i'd never met him before he was very
kind but he he
cursed
and i was like whoa
yes yes that was one and didn't his
voice sound different when yesterday
yeah he was more like
that was shocking to me too where he was
like hey so um he was so laid back and
funny i mean yes yeah but like yeah it's
just sort of like this and are you from
connecticut
yeah i am
i i have a [ __ ] uh friend who lives
and then you go out on the show and it's
like really did you do it
yeah
that's a terrible jay leno
no that's so good and so true and so
that's exactly how [ __ ] sounded coming
out of his mouth like yes you know we're
kind of a weird spot in the sentence
yeah but also just the word itself in
his mouth just was like new
well
it may yeah it made
the experience of then being on the show
that much stranger and more heightened
because he was behaving in a kind of
heightened way um
but you always seem so chill you always
seem
measured and
comfortable on those shows i i like
i never remember seeing but but isn't
that not no you do oh god really nerves
see i think people would be surprised to
hear that
yeah i i don't know if you ever got used
to it did you or
like when you go out on those do you
do you uh
feel like oh yeah i got this and you
just walk out and
no no no but but
no but i was i i have come a long way i
think from being like cripplingly
ins like nervous and sure painfully or
shy and and this is the worst adam is
like overcompensating for those nerves
by being like
trying to perform
uh cool and trying to perform nonchalant
that's right which which is
just
which is just yeah that's not network
those are the ones i can't go back and
look at those are the ones that are
embarrassing
but no i've never never got to the point
of like um
uh okay this is just another person i'm
talking to yeah
yeah
god no and and i also feel like like i'm
doing one uh
tonight and i'm
i'm uh i'm doing kimmel tonight and i oh
no
i'm uh
it's it's like a a
giant chore uh i know
and then once it's over i'm so happy no
no i'm going in there yeah oh isn't it a
great relief isn't it nice when it's
like when you can
enjoy yes
and then there's another guest or a
musical artist and you're just like oh
yeah no they're great this is great i'm
so happy
yeah i didn't know i loved diplo so much
yeah yeah
yeah i know but but at least you can
have um but that story is great by the
way you should tell the jimmy kimmel
story the one about the fake kimono will
come out before this so it'll look like
we it looks like you're rehashing that's
right i heard him tell him god
oh
this again about the fake ids
um and then you you read it in ew and
then you see it somewhere i've told this
story like 18 times
right because now they're all those
things yeah i see it on instagram now
it's like the quotes from people i'm
like well they're still saying that yeah
yeah oh that one's still they think
that's fresh
um
how many kids you have two kids you said
i have seven kids
yeah no i have two kids i have two kids
uh
you're good thirteen-year-old uh
daughter uh frankie and then grammy is
fifteen oh frankie great name yeah
girl was it hard to name them was it was
it a process uh graham i've eventually
figured out because at the time it was
like graham is is the name and it just
felt right and it was like where does
that come from and i thought maybe is it
graham chapman from monty python or
graham loved graham persons maybe we
were kind of figuring but it wasn't
until just a year or so ago
that i re-watched sex lives and
videotape which is a movie i watched
weekly as a teenager i just
oh my god because because ann scott was
cool and let you watch r-rated movies
that's right and i had my own copy and i
would do scenes from it in acting class
i was all about james spade
laura sand jack yeah peter gallagher and
all right
so great have you seen that movie
you know i'm embarrassed to say this and
we have a question coming up that pretty
much you've never seen it i've never
seen it you you
roblox was on the show and i and i
talked about it as though i had seen it
i'm aware of it
i have to see it it's a great movie i
can't believe i ever it's a great movie
no no it's it's it's it came out at a
weird time for you because you were
probably like 12 and why would you want
to why would you see sex lives in
videotape well
i was 12 and there's sex in the title i
remember being like i remember seeing
the uh the poster or the
vhs box we've lost everyone for casual
sex that leah thompson oh victoria
jackson movie and i just felt like just
the idea that like
leah that lorraine bates is on this like
next to the words leah thompson has a
button up yes men's shirt on with
something else one of them is going like
this yeah oh yeah i used to go to the
video store after school not to rent
anything but just to read the boxes
me too for me hours yes i i have uh i
have viv i could like like the back of
my hand if one of those horror movies
that i still haven't seen if one of them
committed a crime i could like do a
perfectly action 100 sketchup
that's why i could name i could give you
the release the the the year
any movie came out from like 1980 on
oh [ __ ] wow i i think i can nightmare
enough streak 2 freddie's revenge
it was 86 uh because i feel like i feel
like the first one was like 84.
85.86 i think it was 85 for this part
two
part two because i remember by the time
i came down here in 91
the one with tom arnold was out and i
went to see it because i didn't know
anyone had nothing else to do and i and
i think it was in 3d and tom arnold was
in it and roseanne barr
that's funny i think
91 there was a
pretty freddy movie of some sort
when people do come up to you is it
about specifically step brothers fans
yeah um yeah do they quote the movies
that is such we were just talking about
how that's such a quotable
movie yeah um yeah i get sometimes the
um the six-pack the catalina wine mixer
people want me to say it to their
friends on oh right facetime or whatever
right um which is totally understandable
i always equated it with when i was a
kid i would have loved to meet william
atherton uh
ghostbusters you know oh yes in all of
the die hard die hard oh yeah
i know i could do this all day
last thing i i wanted to talk about uh
your die hard rem oh yeah yes yeah yeah
i didn't realize this you you you were
an extra in the music video for
drive
it was like a radio contest
and it was like summer of 92
i was back up in santa cruz delivering
pizza uh before i came down for my
second year of school we felt like we
were winning a contest but we were just
signing up for x for background work um
and
so we all got into a car and made a road
trip out of it and it's forever like
this the halcyon days of being
20 years old and getting into a car with
your for your friends and having no
money and driving the length of
california
doing this two nights adventure yeah so
fun and yeah and
figuring out how to get cigarettes and
where are we going to crash and it was
great and in the middle of all of it we
got to
do this music video it was like 6 p.m to
6 a.m for two nights right because it
was outside it was dark
and uh it was at the sepulveda dam
and uh and rem were there who at the
time this is right before automatic for
the people came out so they were like
global superstars so it was like being
at disneyland because there were four
guys walking around just kind of
standing there answering questions or
be just
you know uh being there for us to walk
up to and and meet and stuff
um
and it was it was so much fun and then
you know it wasn't until i had a
scott ackerman and i had an rem podcast
a couple of years ago that i finally
found myself in the music video i had
never been able to
somehow point it out yes a fan was able
to find it find me
so you're like deep background i'm like
you can see my face
in this literally
you know
smashed together crowd of people are you
dancing are you are you just a crowd
watching are you the no the video is
um
michael's type being carried around
crowd surfing and the camera up above
him while he lip syncs while being uh
carried around by all of us under him so
it was
hundreds of people was you did your did
they give you
um did they give you any kind of
instructions about like now when you
touch him there were only certain people
allowed to touch him and stuff no it was
weird he would just like come across
don't touch his taint yeah yeah no taint
touching that was really specific but at
one point they started they got fire
hoses out and started spraying us while
we were doing it
it was cold it was insane
um but we were happy you know yeah isn't
that great in this story have you ever
run into michael stein have you read
occasion to tell him i have for this
podcast we uh ended up uh interviewing
him and mike mills when they were
promoting the re-release of uh
of monster and then afterwards we went
out to dinner with them
and he knew that i was this big fan and
that i was in the drive video and
so
so afterwards we go
to grab dinner with them and like burtis
downs their manager and and other people
from their team or whatever we go into
this restaurant and you know that moment
when you all arrive at the table and
there's like the moment of
where is everyone gonna sit yes right
and it's a little it's just worse yes no
one wants to commit no no one wants to
do anything and someone else but michael
just
knowing
that this is already uh uh
a certain has significance for me he
just says adam why don't you sit between
me and mike
what if mike mills the other member of
varian
and i was like
yeah
and so i got to sit between those guys
uh and so yeah they're really sweet
guys and i i just always loved their
songwriting and just how kind of they're
cool that just the way they presented
themselves was always cool and
mysterious and fun um god i want to
listen to automatic people again the
whole those are the albums where it's
like the whole thing you know like some
groups i love where it's like yeah one
or two songs you'll i'll go to
especially now where like things are so
accessible but uh automatics for the
people i will um
yeah just listen i mean the whole thing
is so it's like absolutely yes totally
[Music]
hey parents this one's for you wundery's
kids and family podcast little stories
everywhere transports your family to an
imaginative world with enchanting
stories and exciting adventures in each
episode hosts virginia madsen and robbie
damond read an original children's tale
if you've been looking for screen free
entertainment for your kids little
stories everywhere encourages your
little ones to use their imaginations in
one of their latest tales you'll hear
about mark the unicorn he's just like
any other unicorn except he doesn't have
a horn that makes him an easy target for
school bullies that is
until he runs into the most popular
unicorn in school sprinkles and their
unexpected adventure changes his life
forever listen to little stories
everywhere on amazon music apple
podcasts or listen early and ad free by
joining wandery plus kids in apple
podcasts or wandery plus in the wondery
app
in business competition is the key to
success every product you own from the
shoes on your feet to the phone in your
hands got there because of cutthroat
business decisions wonders podcast
business wars brings you stories about
the most well-known in the world and how
the decisions they make shape what you
buy and how you live with over 50
seasons to choose from you'll hear about
the fight for your feet with nike versus
adidas the battle to control the
smartphone market with iphone versus
blackberry or their new season that's
covering the delectable world of ice
cream haagen-dazs versus ben and jerry's
tells the story of these two legendary
american brands that have traded licks
trying to conquer the global ice cream
market each season of business wars is
entertaining fun eye opening and will
help you understand a little bit more
about the world around you listen to
business wars on amazon music apple
podcasts or wherever you get your
podcasts listen one week early and add
free by joining wondering plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
um [ __ ] adam all day i can do this we
just have a lightning round i know i'm
taking oh yeah yeah of course yeah i
know um what is your uh favorite emoji
yeah this i knew this was coming uh and
it's it's not great uh it's the thumbs
up uh you know
it's useful
it's
yeah um
uh very useful it's an honest my
favorite
you can use it with anyone and they know
what yeah and it gives it enough of a
tone that it's like kind of
light-hearted there's something
light-hearted about a thumbs up i'm with
you
who is your first celebrity crush
really because the age when you get a
crush where you're like
oh yeah oh i feel something for this
person and it has to happen
it can't happen i mean you can have
these crushes where you're like
i feel an affinity for that person i'm
not exactly sure why but when you
recognize the time where
yeah where you recognize like oh we
could have a life i want to be a part of
that person's life
we could have a life together
yes that was alyssa milano for me that's
so god that is
you would be shocked how often that or
not you wouldn't be shocked how often it
comes up um
i'm sure
and you had her on and you handled it
well i didn't know how to and how do you
say that with that and she must know
that it's
maybe not i wonder i i i
she just has to um i i had uh we did a
scene together in
the wet hot american summer tv series
where we have this big fight and we were
on the ground and she was on top of me
like holding a weapon or something and
just kind of in between takes where
you're just in close proximity with
someone you don't know that way you know
it's weird
strange and so i just said
i have to i have to tell you
that
this is
for
uh you know
12 to 14 year old me this is a huge
huge moment uh or something to that
effect and she was cool about it and now
in retrospect i i probably should have
just i don't think that's kind of
terrible to say those are the moments
like what is this serving
no one and i should have just stopped
talking but she's the best she's really
cool and uh and such a such a
a great advocate for for so many people
i i know i know she i like talking to
her um and i her husband
i used to be with i didn't know dave a
little bit um i've always liked him uh
but i we had patrick wilson on recently
and he's he had said alyssa milano too
and we thought christian and i thought
my brother and i thought oh you know
he he must have been such a hunk we've
had a good shot they're with anyone 100
no he's a beautiful looking person nice
and
into theater
approachable i know that's uh
smart
[Music]
uh yes why did i say well because
um
i then then i thought well well that's
up to alyssa like what was her taste
like i love that we assume like yeah
because as a guy i think patrick
wilson's hunky and like nice not he has
all the attributes i would want
in a in a boyfriend when i was 11. um
but it was also the one-two punch of of
of who's the boss but also commando that
was a big deal those were happening at
the same time she was the daughter and
commander wow
wasn't it weird to see people you knew
from sitcoms in like kind of r-rated
like intense weird yeah
so weird um
what what is your favorite ice cream
flavor oh uh i haven't tried it yet but
i think it would be the everything
bagel flavor at uh jenny's i saw someone
on instagram being like i can't believe
this is delicious and it's it says
everything they i was like if anyone can
do it it's jenny it sounds horrible but
it's um
i believe it's got it's got to be good
and i and i love the everything
but the bagel
shape i love that the seasoning i'll put
that one
what is uh your favorite holiday uh
arbor day probably no um i uh
i guess uh
i guess
christmas
just sort of that time of year i love
that
everything's sort of winding down but
winding down towards
just sitting around in your sweats
watching tv
i know and
it's great this is sort of a great
yeah it's a great time to catch up on
severance
um great time to
dig in yeah everyone in seven months
get on severus
um we sort of mentioned this earlier
what is an acclaimed movie that you
you're embarrassed to admit you haven't
seen or you people kind of shame you for
nothing sure i don't know yeah dirt i've
never seen dirty dancing oh yeah that's
so funny christian we talk about that on
the show he he finally saw it for the
first time what did he say about it he
oh it might have been pretty woman where
he would ah no he said dirty dancing to
her he was like i mean it's good yeah
it's good i hope people don't get mad
because it's such a beloved movie yeah
um i think it might be more
and his fiance said you know it might be
more just like a
like a female
centric movie you know it might be one
of those things like i love i love inner
space like inner space too i love inner
space man and right
but i brought that up with
some there are people who are like oh
yeah it's good and i think it still
holds up and
it's people
who i trust who i love who i like sense
of humor i trust like yeah really i'm
not crazy about that and it always
confounds me so i i get when people have
a real attachment to a movie inner space
does
we showed it to the kids when they were
littler like in like five to seven and
it was good it's good and the effects
it's fun to watch movies like that where
you're like these effects are good this
is no good i know superman is like that
for me i recently watched like
christian was obsessed with superman
three and and we saw that and we were
like it's kind of like ahead of its time
superman three it's like all about
computers took a long time richard pryor
one yeah he was great and he was like so
fun even though you hear stories about
it it's like he was collecting a
paycheck and like whatever but she's
pretty fun um but yeah those effects
like i get that they're
maybe a little but they still maybe it's
just because we knew them as kids we saw
we were like impressed with them as kids
yeah yeah i don't know um yeah inner
space
still holds up that's really good
my meg ryan crush kind of i think that
was a moment where i was like oh i have
this is someone i could like
i could make a life with
this person
at eight years old oh that's right
what what is a game show pastor present
that you'd like to be i know you've done
some of those game shows oh oh i i liked
match game because everyone was like
[ __ ] around i i loved that yeah yeah
that was kind of like a little body yeah
um what is uh what do you drink coffee
or tea and coffee i i i drink it black
and
espresso and i drink it all day
oh really yeah it's you know i drink too
much
i i am off it now because you are
because of your sickness
well it was right before the sickness i
went to see
this really brilliant acupuncture sound
so
if we haven't sounded like douchey la
actors i it's this my acupuncturist
shout out andre recommended it um you
should that by looking at my tongue
she's like i think you should cut out
caffeine i just trusted her she's she
and and so i've been not caffeine coffee
specifically so i've been drinking
green tea which still gives you know
it's a good amount of caffeine in it it
doesn't yeah and less but also but
enough so i don't get those like
withdrawal headaches that you know
occasionally um but i do miss the ritual
i miss the like the taste
yeah i love it yeah
yeah um
i worked at the coffee shop too for used
to what he did like coffee shops um yeah
for years i wish i wanted a job there in
a video store or record store i could
never get a job at any of those places
oh i applied to blockbuster me too
yes it's hard to get those jobs
yeah well who's laughing now yeah
exactly yeah blockbuster um
yeah if you could learn another language
what would it be
probably spanish because it would uh be
i would be able to uh use it uh a lot
and i always feel like a boob for not
knowing more spanish and yes like we
should all be fluent in spanish i know
i've been i've been taking classes shout
out to sergio at the beverly hills
linguist
center yeah it's great it's um it's it's
you know zoom you do it zoom and it's
like so smart it was it was kind of fun
being back in
and like being around other students too
um recommend it uh
sergio's grace if you want to choose a
seizure that's great
um what is your favorite cereal adam you
know what i really like i love the
trader joe's peanut butter granola it's
delicious
in the blue bag
it's it's really good growing up i like
the kind
peanut butter granola oh yeah that's
really good too yeah um growing up it
was probably like honey nut cheerios
which is still just it's like a perfect
stone
yes
well that changed a lot when i when i
i i
started rethinking cereal as being like
a dessert when we were uh-huh my brother
and i would look for we would be stoned
and wanting not wanting to eat like
too
shitty um
and so when you make that adjustment
it's it's a game changer yeah
it's really good
um i mean cinnamon toast crunch like oh
it's really good yeah and so and and was
cool in terms of like
nutrition and stuff too yeah no we
didn't get i didn't get sugar cereal any
any of that stuff so honey nut cheerios
was a major treat uh even cheerios
cheerios wasn't really there was a lot
of corporate uh
general mills serial in that in the
house but uh
but yeah were there words
and were there words that she would not
want you to use i mean were there words
like that where like we're off limits
like
this
c word c word
it's not yeah the original uh
probably although i'm not really
remembering i wonder if that word
i mean it was around i just don't really
remember it
i don't remember either that word was so
extreme
[Music]
yeah yeah
to me it's replaced [ __ ] if you really
are like wanna dig into somebody like uh
yeah especially calling uh
a a man a man
that word
oh no i only mean man wait i should make
that clear yeah oh no no put that out
there yes yes
really
gets down to it when that's the word for
you know guy who says it you know who
says it the best is al pacino in
glengarry glenn ross oh yeah i remember
100
it's so definitive it's so like yeah
dismissive and like yeah it it's so
convicted the way he says it about him
he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah enough
um what a movie
so good
if you had to choose a different first
name what would it be god that's a
really good question uh he's got a
really strong name it's two first names
it's two first names yeah um
oh you know what what name i really uh
like is um
uh [ __ ] what was it
i always liked the name
graham like i said so i i named it oh
yeah
um but uh
and graham came from
um
was your wife
on board with graham
yeah yeah she was it's just i think it's
a scottish name but i think the scottish
it's it's spelled differently um yeah i
guess i'll just stick with that because
i can't think of this other one
yeah well if it comes to mind um all
right now i'm really curious i was like
mildly curious at first and now [ __ ] was
it
well it must not be
it must be speaking of the boomer
welcome to the boomer hour i can't
remember anything
um if you had a sandwich named after you
uh the the adam scott sandwich the what
would be on it what would your well if
you were to build one
sure i i really like uh i like it when
you throw in a couple different meats
like a turkey and ham with cheddar
cheese
with uh lettuce and
like a few different things um and i
love a pretzel roll
oh yeah oh it's really a great
addition to a sandwich i always choose
that if there's a choice of bread i mean
it sounds bougie on a plane if they're
like hey i always choose the pretzel
roll pretzel roll
um yeah
yeah
what would there be would you moisten it
you mean with like uh gravy or like a
condiment yes yeah yeah
oh yeah uh
mayonnaise and and you know
now with uh modern technology they've
made um the sort of veganaise just as
delicious as mayonnaise
so it's like that on there no i'm not at
all no you turkey and ham you mentioned
yeah yeah but i for whatever reason
veganize is we just keep it and in the
fridge and then like dijon mustard and
then you know what i like on a sandwich
lots of salt and pepper
in there
okay in addition to the saltiness of the
yeah cured meats oh yeah yeah yeah um
what is your favorite uh tom hanks movie
uh
um
that's a really good question uh now i'm
thinking 80s because like i mean people
say big a lot or speaks
splash splash is a kick-ass movie have
you seen that
recently i have not i want to because it
keeps coming up and i wanna
and and i
john candy's is like i try to oh man i
see that would be heartbreaking if my
kids if i sat them down and they watched
planes trains and automobiles and they
were like restless and like i don't get
it no that their kids love playing
trains and only automobiles and they do
they did love splash now you watch it
you're like it's like a sundance movie
like it's this
really
scrappy little story
that has this sort of big finish but
it's not that big it's really good
is it wrong it might be splash ron
howard yeah it might be splash um but i
i i really love
um
uh castaway i really love castaway oh
yes oh man that feels good
also that his his
that's his movie star like that's the
thing that separates him as a movie star
i think that's when it then it becomes
so apparent that like he can hold his
screen oh yeah alone
for
a wonderful movie essentially yeah i
know and make it like dynamic
so engaging yeah and everyone feels like
they need to see that movie that's like
a
movie star that we don't get totally uh
uh i i love apollo 13. it's
yeah terrific movie god he had i mean
it's just one after another um
uh he makes me yeah um
now i'm hung up on step brothers people
loving that movie as much as these
movies what i i have to ask you because
rob what wriggle was on talking about
the pow to how that came about like now
um oh yeah
how he because i'm fascinated by because
i love outtakes and i'm fascinated by
how in scenes like that how
who breaks first who holds on who's like
the strongest um when you're doing a
scene with yeah john c reilly and will
ferrell like who
who goes first i've worked i know john
is very
committed yes
um
what was that like was it was it scary
the prospect of breaking around it was
scary
uh completely because i was i got cast
as it was a fluke because someone else
had the role and and then had to bail
oh man and so they were casted quickly
and so i just got the part having never
really done
much
comedy you know i was just sort of like
thrown in there didn't really know what
i was doing improv wise and so i kind of
learned all of that stuff
while making the movie that's why which
is like and i've equate i've said it
before but kind of equating it to
learning how to like
do the long jump at the olympics right
yes yes yeah yeah learning basketball
with the 95 bulls with like the all-star
team yeah exactly so
i yeah it was pretty rough for a lot of
it and they cut me together very
generously
but by the end you know it was a few you
know four months or whatever by the end
i was like okay by the way catherine
hahn was in the same position as me but
like a superstar from day one like
knowing exactly what she was doing oh
wow wow what was it that you felt like
untethered to what was it about was it
the improv well i remember being at the
i just got the role and i was at the
super bad premiere this is like how long
ago this was we're at the premiere were
you there i'm sure you were there we
were probably hanging out in the same
little vip everything yes i think we
work
and i saw judd and he was like hey
congratulations because it was like that
day or the day before
that i got the got the roll he's like
congratulations i i told you that little
roland knocked up would [ __ ] pay off
or something like he made some joke um
and it's true shauna robertson got me
because i was friends with right so i
was sort of around i feel like we were
around some of those same like
parties and stuff with that poor group
of people
and i was around because i was friends
with rudd and then shauna
just plugged me into knocked up and i
got that little
that little
uh role in that and so i kind of got to
know judd a little bit and then so when
step brothers came around that i'm sure
kind of helped me uh landed but anyway
he was like yeah um and i was like so
hey
just real quick i don't i i'm not like
the most experienced in like improv and
stuff what uh i'm and i know those guys
do that uh what and this is at the party
like people and he's like uh what was
that yeah
so i was like yeah and he goes listen
write down jokes write them down and
just keep keep a piece of paper in your
just write down jokes for whatever scene
you're doing seth does everybody does it
i was like hmm
okay yeah and so
i remember before that the scene in the
treehouse where i go up there and and
they punch me in the f that's yeah you
want to punch me don't you yeah yeah i
remember before that
i had written down a bunch of jokes on a
piece of paper
and i remember being so freaked out in
that scene
and running out of things to say that on
camera i like pulled this piece of paper
out and i was like
i haven't had a car since 2004 like [ __ ]
like that like i didn't know that's what
i was doing
and
oh god that's funny
but there are great lines but then you
think like
well if they aren't they're really funny
lines i imagine
the scene with the dane cooks on soon
when you're in the car was probably
easier because you could hide the sheet
out that's right i could have that yeah
that's funny well man yeah it's so good
it's
it's one of the you must hear this all
the time it is i i have to like
it's a it's like you said when you you
know if you were a kid and you run into
somebody like
harrison ford or something you have to
say something like i that i that movie
is so dear to me it's probably so much
joy that like i have to
just tell you how much i love it oh well
if i wasn't you and i i'm sure i would i
would be i would be watching it a
thousand times too because yeah i'd love
it too i think it's
those guys are the best they're they're
the very best and very funniest yeah
would you rather take a time machine to
the past or the future the past i would
like to to go to the past i would like
to go to like the early 80s uh
yeah
uh are you more of a talker or a texter
texter i think texting has um
has solved a lot of communication issues
for me as far as because i have an
anxiety about answering the phone like i
don't know how long this is gonna go i
don't know exactly who it is
yes i've tried to pinpoint this the
specific source of the anxiety and it's
i think it's the i the uncertainty
around how
how it's going to end i have no control
over
i'm not saying well i i know i always
admire people who are like
i have you know jerry o'connell yeah
dude
yeah yeah it's jeremy's really good
that's jerry great guy but he's okay
if he gets the slightest hint
that like you know you you introduce the
wind down in you in the tone like well
anyway so it's sort of like
well um
listen you know it's a version of that
like yeah the conversations he knows
he'll go yep okay buddy i'll see you
later that's right and
i wish
i could do that i gotta go and i i i get
panicky about
needing to explain why i have to go
that's right having a good
during the it's like when you're
listening to stern and he says
listen you've done it all or you've said
it all and people don't get it and they
keep talking it's like no howard needs
to howard needs to wrap it up he needs
to yes yes that's such a good yeah i'm
gonna hear his voice now yeah uh you've
done it all you've said it on yeah
um uh are you at night or morning person
adam night
for sure
you have a ritual you have a thing you
like to do i mean at this point the kids
are old enough you don't have to yeah i
yeah putting them to bed is no longer
really a thing making sure they go to
sleep at some point but uh
yeah it's like
i love
ipad i'm you know we're
again the the old man hour but having
the world's library of films and
television at my fingertips with yeah
headphones that are
great and accessible like i can lay down
and watch anything i want it's great and
what what is on um what's on the docket
what is the thing that you uh
dirty do why haven't you seen dirty
pants i don't know but i need to watch
that and you need to watch sex lives in
videotape i think that's what it is yes
yeah um
are you did you prefer the toilet roll
over or you have any preference that
under or over uh
under seems more logical but for
whatever reason over gives me less agita
me too just visually it's more it's
more comfortable it seems more
accessible do you own i'm looking at
your space now do you own any nick off
from in pieces any any uh shower in our
backyard uh he really built he put this
yeah i thought he used he uses he used
he's he's out there now just washing up
oh cool first of all cool that you have
an outdoor shower yeah
oh yeah yeah and it's beautiful he uh
and oh yeah
i can put that in for you yeah yeah and
he did it in like three days
do you do i bet you do an offerman i
don't i can't do it i wish i could do
impressions like you do incredible
impressions i i can't really do any
i did michael keaton in high
school uh
but i i don't i wouldn't i wouldn't know
how to it was something about him
talking about soup in batman
he's talking about
no i'd love to hear it yeah i i don't
even remember i i know i can't i just
don't have that
yes soup i do remember it's the way he
said soup it's with he offers tim
basinger soup that's what it is
i think we have soup um yeah alfred
alfred yeah because they're at the ends
of the table
yes are you enjoying your soup yeah
that's right that's right she's tr yeah
and there's that awkward like
yeah you like yourself and you have to
crane over to he's gonna hurt him yes
yes yes oh my god
um okay and this is it uh this is the
last please finish this sentence adam
scott life is short so don't forget to
just
you know what
just take it easy
just
take it
easy i love that you know
just [ __ ]
chill
okay
you know it's that kind of that has
become wisdom to me you know when when
those simple
um easily accessible you would think
that would be like a duh yeah or like
kind of trite it becomes profound when
you apply it to life yeah
um i know i know there's so much to
worry about and take on and
i know yeah
i know to i sometimes forget to
breathe properly and enjoy i know yeah
it's a good reminder yeah um well
please take it easy i i have you too man
yeah this is great
yeah i'm glad we got to do this is when
like having this thing this podcast is
like purely selfish because like you're
somebody i've always wanted to like
you know talk hang out with and yeah we
just kind of run into each other every
couple of years um and
yeah and
like i said i've been enjoying it i
really just took
one of the recent episodes with steve
zahn was so much fun to listen to oh man
you're i don't know him at all but
you're asking all those things that i
wanted to know and oh that's great it's
great it's great so yeah you're doing a
really and your brother is hilarious and
great too so
uh yeah it's a great show it's great
well we're that'll mean a lot to him it
means a lot to me because we're such
fans of yours thanks pal that thank you
for saying that um and let's do
something again let's do it let's do
more yeah
that would be terrific
all right all right take it easy
so that just happened so that just
happened neutral yeah there's a little
bit maybe it's a little higher than mine
you're very similar yeah i will say it's
like you know he's a few years older but
you you just seem very similar to me as
people yeah you have very similar senses
of humor i know i say this often and i'm
starting to get sick of hearing myself
say but i i could really be friends with
him i could easily absolutely that's and
it's weird i i've been saying that more
often but it is it feels like a rare
thing to feel that to have that
connection with somebody where you can
feel like oh it is you know with just a
little bit of effort
i think i i mean i know this is like i'm
assuming that he might want this
presumptuous on my part i think he would
but it's also like he works all the time
yeah he's got a family he's got a wife
like
i you know it's hard i think i think
it's hard to make new friends oh yeah
now at our age
and the main reason is just because of
all the other things going on i know you
know well i say this often too but
that's one of the reasons i really love
doing this is like i get to like hang
out with people that i i think i
normally if i had a little bit more time
if i was in my 20s there were fewer
responsibilities i'd probably cultivate
a friendship with but here's the problem
and it's not try to it's not necessarily
a long-term problem but up until now in
the show we we haven't had any repeat
guests
so
there is something a little sad about
having a really good conversation for
you make a friend with someone and know
that you're never gonna i know not never
gonna see them again but like on the
show you're never gonna see them again
and if you don't cultivate like a real
life friendship yeah then it is a
one-and-done situation ah that's true
sorry to make it negative
that's true but you know that's but i
feel like eventually we probably will
start repeating guests right i think so
i've been thinking about that i i feel
like just start from the beginning yeah
and just like go in order why not yeah
um we sh we certainly should have jerry
on again of course and dancing well i've
been pushing for jerry and you always
say we don't have time in the episode to
call them not true it's the opposite of
that is you know why you're laughing
cherry it's not true i must say i must
compliment you i must compliment you
that you um handled yourself very well
despite having covid during that
interview could you hear it in my voice
sure could oh you coughed occasionally
yeah
it was real trooper but i i understand
why you pulled it together for someone
like adams yeah i didn't want to cancel
that one and and i felt like i was well
enough obviously to
have a conversation with somebody and
actually i was it was like day
i don't know five or six of my covenants
so i was kind of looking forward to
having i hadn't really socialized in a
while
yeah so it was if you could hear that
maybe too i could hear that yeah it's um
it was a good one
it was fun to talk to him you're
embarrassed
one of the weirdest stories from your
youth i think with the the story where
you
first time you swear and you like go out
into a field by yourself yeah i know
it's one of my clearest memories it's
such a weird story i know and it's like
so funny to
it's like one of those things i mean
obviously it's not like if i had a time
machine it's not the first place i'd go
but if i had like i'd like to see a ton
of trips to the past yeah
i would definitely go there like a day
pass you had like um no i would need
more than a day pass
like no i mean like you could go every
you use it every day for i meant like oh
okay i can yeah yeah eventually i would
go to this moment it would be funny to
see you like yeah i'd like to whispering
that to yourself yeah also to see how
different it was or to see
how i what my face looked like after i
said it or because i do remember feeling
i think that's why i remember it because
it was like a formative it was it was i
don't want to say traumatic it wasn't
trauma but it was like i remember
feeling really guilt-ridden and you're
sure it was ass and not an [ __ ] it
wasn't [ __ ] i wouldn't have the nerve
to say that
no way that was way too advanced i i was
like i wanted to start lighter i think
less severe in case i was struck by
light in case something did happen like
there was some wrath that that being
you were that uh like scared of
yeah hell yeah really yeah yeah because
i remember seeing like i remember really
like taking in a lot of artwork from
like a renaissance art that was or i
guess pre-renaissance was a
pre-renaissance that was like all you
know medieval depictions baroque yeah i
guess more baroque that was heaven and
hell and all like religious iconography
i remember taking in some of the more
gruesome ones i i was attracted to the
like
gruesome ones like the ones of the
martyrs and deaths and the black plague
i mean there were some pretty uh grim
subjects that you painted back then and
i remember being really like and pop and
pie had all those books you know yeah it
was part of our youth yes it sure was
part of our lives yes i know something
to uh you know discuss and figure out
chip away yeah maybe it's funny that
adam scott was in automatic for the
people uh oh yeah
drive music video i love that story yeah
he was such a fan
such a great album oh my god that that
album automatic for the people that
album i associate with
like just starting to ironically drive a
car yeah when i got my license i was
driving
it was like preparing station wagon and
i remember like blasting automatically
for the people in the tape deck yes i
sound so old i know and thinking
remember thinking like people would
think you're cool i'm it's i've never
felt to this day i've never felt cooler
like that feeling of the wind like
rushing in the car
people hearing you playing i know about
music but isn't it crazy how time what
time does to you and
that i just had i just saw a teenager
like screaming up the hill where we live
in
probably his father's bmw um and just
like blasting music and driving too fast
and i thought you damn kid
like to slow down no one wants to hear
your music uh and and like
get your own car i know i had all these
thoughts i know but we didn't we also
wouldn't have been so reckless
we also drove a station wagon
probably a fairly moderate speed and a
multi-colored uh volkswagen golf um oh
yeah you had an 83 golf which i couldn't
say
wolf golf
um pretty woman was the movie not dirty
dancing oh that i recently saw finally
and i was like uh it's good it's good i
thought it was like dancing no i had
seen that i've seen that uh
a few times but yeah pretty woman i
finally saw and it was good
but it was hyped up for so many years
from so many people isn't that weird
it's like alexander it's good in a
non-constitutional role not only that
but like a really despicable yeah i know
i know like problems
yeah oh you know oh you i thought you
had enough of it i've seen like uh and i
know that i've seen scenes of his like
problematic
aggressive uh-huh with her oh with her
oh i did yeah yeah
if you see that movie through the lens
of you know 2022
eyes uh
it is problematic for sure two things i
learned about you uh-huh during this uh
conversation oh wow uh one you have an
acupuncturist and two
and two
you're taking spanish classes with a man
named sergio yes i
both
exciting things to learn listen if
sergio's listening since i talked to
adam i have not really been on top of
the classes i'm supposed to go every
thursday
but i have not gone so i
listening i apologize
to him but it's a great program
i've only been to two but it's um the
beverly hills linguist center expanding
your horizons i like it yeah and the
acupuncturist um andrea shout out uh is
incredible let's read a letter okay
great letter time do we need a fee
letter letter time letter time letter
letter letter letter letter time it's
letter time
from michaela quinn hi justin and
christian
my name is michaela and i live in a town
south of boston but i grew up in east
hartford connecticut cool
you guys are so funny and relatable and
i'm a huge fan of your podcast thank you
michaela i drive students with
disabilities to and from school every
day so i'm in the car six plus hours a
day
listening to your podcast makes the day
go by faster and the students love the
would you rather conversations that's
hilarious
she reads
she reads she listens she lists
you know this is a podcast right
she reads a transcript of the podcast to
the students it's dangerous too to be
holding yeah um that is so cool that's
so nice to think about
uh thank you michaela
how much would you love to to over here
to like be a fly in that bus the walls
of that bus i like that um some of my
favorite episodes have been anna klumsky
my girl is one of my favorite movies
vince vaughn hey max greenfield yes love
you man everyone is a great one teresa
caputo
and jake johnson those are some of my
favorites too
the only two podcasts i listen to are
life is short and welcome to our show oh
must be a new girl fan she is the few
epis she goes she goes on to say the few
episodes of new girl with paul
genslinger in them are some of my
favorites and i wish she was in all of
them oh thank you michaela yeah i love
doing that show
um thank you guys for making my work
days 100 more enjoyable do you think
you'll ever have adam sandler on the
show that'd be awesome that would be
really awesome that would be
landing a whale it would um
you know i should reach out to alan
covert his uh his right hand
because adam i know a little bit from
back in the day um but yeah that'd be
great fingers crossed fingers crossed
okay
michaela is a would you rather
lose your sense of taste and only smell
bad things forever oof
and only smell bad things forever
wow so you don't taste anything
but you smell bad things all the time
or do you smell bad things when you're
near bad things that's what i'm
wondering
only smell bad things forever let's say
when you're near bad things you smell
them rather than have like a like a like
you don't
and
smell
scent in your nose all the time exactly
and you don't smell flowers but you
smell dog [ __ ] right
even when you smell flowers you smell
dog [ __ ] no i don't i mean when you now
so when you smell the flowers i see you
don't smell them
you don't smell anything
and like nothing yes these registers but
when you're standing over dog [ __ ] that
smells bad weirdly at this unless i mean
it's all relative if you like the small
dog some people might like do you think
there's any what percent i mean it's got
to be less than one but dog [ __ ] is
truly inoffensive really i don't mind
manure so much
um but step brothers dog shit's horrible
horrible this scene is that the with the
white dog show yes horrible and the and
the sound will ferrell makes is
something that you feel when you're
watching it he's like
he like screams
it's so good um okay that sounds pretty
bad i'm curious what the other one is or
lose your sense of smell and only taste
bad things forever
wait lose your sense of smell okay no
smell
and only taste bad things right so the
bad things she might mean
everything tastes bad yeah i would
rather uh
i would rather
have my taste be neutral and bad smells
because taste is more
like
eating is important and like obviously
it would suck i think in both scenarios
like one
things don't taste like anything and the
other things taste like [ __ ] but i
wouldn't want to live a life where
everything i tasted was horrible yeah
because you have to keep eating like you
don't have to i mean obviously you have
to smell but you don't have to be
you can avoid certain bad smells and
like so what yeah smell also sometimes
bad smells are good to have it's good to
have that sense to to know when
something smells bad it's why you know
if you smell gas or something or you
yeah i don't think that that's bad
though i i like the smell of gas i know
you're i know you're saying your point
is i like the smell of well no you're
saying like it's
good to have a smell because it's it's a
preventative it's preventative but it's
but gas is not an example of a bad smell
like yes too
there's not that's the thing with women
there's not that many like i don't like
a lot of like i don't like body odor
city smells like yeah i don't know the
armpit of a city but it's not that bad
you live with it pretty trash like sweet
trash like city trash like fermenting in
the sun i don't mind that you don't if i
don't i really hate like fishy trash
pukey fishy
is too terrible terrible but how often
do you smell anything rotten anything
rotten that's why um i mean that's why
we have it in us to to be to be repelled
by those sins unless she means that it
is just always in your
like every time she might because every
time you breathe in you smell dog [ __ ]
she might because she then says lose
your sense of smell and only taste bad
things forever
to taste something that i think i think
maybe she means let's say she means that
oof
that's tough lose your sense of taste
and only smell bad things forever i but
but you smell more than you eat so i
would say
i do yeah if it's that then you have to
yeah i guess you have to
lose the taste yeah
no i mean i mean lose the sense of smell
yeah and only taste bad things and then
hopefully you get used to it
they didn't
that's the thing about a bad taste or a
bad smell
eventually my guess is that you would
get somewhat used to it probably taste
more than yeah but for this hypothetical
to work you don't get used to it right
yeah that's true i was just talking
about bad tastes um we were talking
about that that thing in scandinavia
it's a type of um herring it's like a
pickled herring oh uh yeah i just i just
uh have you seen those videos no no but
i just uh um have you seen the steve
harvey the judge steve harvey show no
it's pretty great i bet i love snapchat
oh you should watch it oh really yeah um
he presides over it's like people's
court and but obviously he's not a
qualified judge but he
presides like he is
and someone
two people two friends just came in and
they had a bet going that one of them
didn't
uh like
finish the bet basically like he didn't
the bet would he lost the bed and he was
just eat three
uh herring like three whole herring
it might have been that that
scandinavian oh maybe he picked him and
apparently it's like what's
um people leave the room when they open
people have to like run out of the room
people throw up immediately he threw up
that's why he didn't oh it's that i bet
oh yeah okay oh my god yes there's that
and then there's a type of flower
there's a type of um
it's uh it's so pungent it's so horrible
or like limburger cheese that'd be tough
for you right yeah really bad cheese oh
man i can feel like this yeah that's bad
um
okay uh and michaela says thank you
michaela quinn sorry mikayla to
oh man i think i had that he's funny
about sense memory i can i have a sense
memory of that of a bad cheese smell
anywho anywho any who uh thank you
michaela and thank you oh my my buddy my
hopefully one day
one day when his kids are grown and he's
got more time to socialize hopefully we
become good friends your real life
friend yeah
adam uh thank you adam that was kind of
how fun and everyone should watch
severance
apple tv it is so good and a little um
future not a spoiler but a little tease
we might have another important
component of the severance show
uh on a future episode very soon so uh
stay tuned for that and for all of our
whoever we have on it's gonna be yeah
how about listen to them all yeah yes
um so thank you to everyone also also if
you would like to write into the show
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
and we will
talk to you next week
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan b monaco and katie b allen senior
producers michelle miesch lans audio
engineer we've just talked about him but
we'll say him again sergio enriquez and
we executive producer he is a man with
sort of dusty blonde why is brunette
more of a brunette
handsome tall went to harvard i believe
very impressive man marshall louie for
wondering
[Music]
okay when it comes to severance
it's it's like it because it's more of
like a mystery and a puzzle
it it's kind of like
hard to do it when you're stoned
but it also
is like kind of makes it more fun when
you're stoned too because it is hard
well
severance that's my stone severance
review
if you like our show please give us a
five star rating and a review and be
sure to tell your friends the next
episode will be out in a week but you
can listen to it right now ad free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app you can follow this show on amazon
music apple podcast and the wondery app
or wherever you're listening right now
in the episode notes you'll find some
links and offers from our sponsors
please support them another way you can
show support for the show is by filling
out a survey at wundery.com survey so
thank you for supporting